what's up guys welcome to VidCon 2017
this is the seventh VidCon that I've
been to I am kind of in shock that I've
been going to this many last year I
wasn't able to make it though because I
went to Germany but we're back this year
VidCon oh my gosh let's do it all up and
he needs to call those YouTube creators
[Music]
here we're heading so I read up now and
this is how I roll
literally
I probably already know but Steve the
knight has done premiered today okay so
does anybody not get buried alive or
that just that reserved for me only
you're the lucky one it's just you but
there are some pretty crazy stuff so
happen I can't wait to see it
oh man we watched the last season like I
watch it with my whole family like we
watched on TV like this is really
special Marian
yeah well this season is I had a bigger
budget that means more people died
yeah and crazier ways uh basically this
season there's like a new monster every
episode so we're dealing with I love it
and guess who this is here
Francesca oh hi how are you great how
are you and this carefully haven't seen
you in Joey and Homer
Joey has my pal
hi Ally Paolo all right how are you guys
this is great so I decided watching
you've got some crazy like cartoons and
all kinds of things you get a voice one
she's gonna be childish we're going to
make her this girl that gets buried
alive it's going to be phenomenal I love
being very loud oh and it's going to be
animated so you don't have to get the
dirt on you I love doing video because I
can just sit in my pajamas and do like a
hot mess I'm like cool this is me nobody
knows my secret great
you can also Joe I'm very the
generational jugular for like ten years
really yeah yeah that's a long time when
did you start when I was 15 I started
juggling now animation all the time 24/7
we're going to cook something right yeah
well I want to learn to juggle knives
uh-huh so how do we have something that
has to be chopped
that way when we cook it we try and
juggle chop it I'm thinking we can do
with you can go out my backyard because
I feel like I've got a little more room
there you can juggle I can juggle items
and then you can charge a barbecue you
have a barbecue no what I can do with on
Amazon yeah this is hell
okay
are you I am wonderful I miss p3 but you
know what was so nice watching you at e3
this year made me feel like I was there
well thank you good job thank you when
you said you weren't going to be there
and like you're probably going to be
able to make so much more content not
being there that's what I literally
crank it out
I would really script in Francis videos
this year a couple of went out pretty
viral was really having a hard year yeah
and you and I miss playing games how was
battlefront was actually really fun I
mean I like the first one and I'm super
excited about this one it is actually a
story mode too and I can plays ray I
can't wait I really really like this
year's e3 everybody else calls it a
snoozer right this is like a lot of the
same games from last year that we're
waiting on yeah but I'm still excited
about all the games I have two years for
the excitement pump in or Bolliger play
battlefront I missed like last of us
wasn't anywhere that sucked but Laura
made it but so good to see you you too
I'm so glad you made up the color chair
I'm so glad y'all came again the people
who don't know we go way back to the
gaming or three or four years yeah first
time meeting and we hosted we actually
presented together awesome know someone
and I felt loved you favorite how did
the VidCon all right I absolutely will
you know you just made my VidCon right
here so I'm so glad you Anna
I love your dog oh but Maddy is so cute
you we need to meet when are we getting
a playdate we need to happen I'll upload
Maggie out of flames and come out the
visit oh please I send it the last
modify your Disney and still hasn't
happened yet but it will happen the same
you can't even get into a car he can't
even I would like taking him to the vet
with an entire ordeal you're gonna see
Maddie and be like uh-uh
get out of here this is my ground
your camera is really oh my god oh okay
oh you're so stupid you're going to be a
big boy now at e3 now I've been climbing
into me how are you I'm going by you a
little plane in Delhi one has a plane
and then we on a movie thing is just
like we're all over the place
the plane is very memorable what
happened to Pittsburgh is all connecting
small world
are you guys loving VidCon so far yeah
lots of fun craziness going on it was
fun you guys look so cute hey I found a
fellow cool band like this is this is
amazing okay show us your pack how long
have you been watching my video oh my
god I find your elastic we just it's
great circle all the Care Hospice in the
camera
you remember I think you're actually in
my first Lowell video alright well no
yeah they're very video I don't think it
was that good actually medium I don't
remember what it was it was something it
was something mediocre really if you are
wait in football yeah that's right
yeah we have a long adventure yes these
are all they can happen and now here we
are
oh my loves you guys get intimidated is
amazing this quality is really great
front-facing camera really good hey guys
where we going today
San Bernardino Bernardino Deena it's so
far away we're going to see tool I saw
them not too long ago in Pittsburgh and
it was the best thing ever
well we have an hour and 27 minutes to
go to get there so we're basically going
to get there just in time to see them
and then we have to leave a little bit
early because there's 55 to help people
this is descent you that's a lot of
people here's the thing I mean out of
all four of us I mean I mean I guess and
you're like I know the fan - yeah right
okay that's well that's news to me
that's like he like certainly set up
beautiful a go oh wait a minute why do I
go in gentle bunny with a band and
Francesca you can't see her she walked
over here that's where I am
yeah what is that what was that scream
oh I fell asleep how am I in the chair
but the chairs probably a genius not
justice but justice will go
I meant it to all consortium out when I
was in high school yeah those are the
those are the days I mean when listen to
him right now get both pumped up thank
you
[Music]
I don't even know how to listen a tool
if I want to because you say they're not
on streaming they're nowhere like you
have to look at them on YouTube okay I
can do that tape digital doesn't work
digital have you heard of it
they're on our way that's what we're
doing I just wanted to say hello this is
also a part of my VidCon vlog I thought
nothing at VidCon at all I did so many
things they were so back to back old
widow crops rough films so but that
Maddie's not feeling well Oh Matt's
watching good here's an employee Tony
and I think it's because I fed of so
many treats through the birthday okay my
fault your disease action crap off the
stream he's a stray dog
okay cool let's go - cool
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]